KATHY PHAM: Hello!
Thank you for hanging
out after lunch
and listening to me tell
you a little bit more
about the United
States Digital Service.
It is incredibly
exciting for me.
And I felt so much
happiness in it
today just to be back
here at home at Google
and to share the
story with you all.
So before I jump
into all the work
that we're doing at
the federal level,
I'll tell you a little
bit about myself.
Who am I?
I am lover of data.
I studied computer
science at Georgia Tech.
I also founded the
Atlanta chapter of Unite
for Sight, while
I was in college,
when we were looking to
eradicate blindness--
or preventable blindness--
around the world-- mainly
cataracts.
I went to this thing
called the Imagine Cup.
Those of you who are far
more familiar with Microsoft
know that it is an
international competition,
similar like the World Cup,
but instead of for soccer,
it's for tech nerds who want
to solve social problems.
And our team brought home
first place for the US.
So I have this weave
of public service
throughout my life and career.
And there's a photo
of Google Health
up there because it wasn't
until I joined the Google Health
team that I realized
I can do something
with my career in technology
and health care as my day job.
I had no idea that even existed.
And I included a
photo of me surfing
just because it's something that
I just also really, really love
doing.
And my husband, who's
here in the front,
was the one who taught
me how to do so.
But also, in addition
to that, I am
what I call a hospital
hustling, cancer fighting,
patient advocate for my mom
who has beat leukemia twice.
And we spent many
countless days and hours--
she's actually right here.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you to Women Techmakers
for inviting my family out.
And I just have to say,
talking to a roomful of women
is very, very exciting,
but having your mom
in the front row
is extremely scary.
And so with all of
that-- with these things
I have found in my life--
whether I chose them
like computer science,
and public service,
and entering these
crazy competitions,
or having cancer just
fall into our lap,
and having to figure out
how to deal with that-- I'll
talk about how that
led me to this place,
where I somehow found
myself as the First Lady's
guest of the State of
the Union Address--
an event that I got to
share with my brother, who
is a captain of
the Marine Corps--
and also work on something
that is now known
as the startup of this man, the
President of the United States,
the United States
Digital Service.
And while there, I got to do
some pretty exciting things.
I got to focus on a
very national level,
looking into issues
that deal with STEM.
This is something
called SOSTEM, which
is like the State of
the Union Address,
but instead is the State
of Science, Technology,
Engineering and Math.
And there was a panel last
year that I contributed to,
which was pretty exciting.
And I have to give
a shout out to Megan
here, since some
of you may know,
she kicked off Women
Techmakers-- incredible woman,
is now the CTO of
the United States.
But Women Techmakers
wouldn't be what
it is today without
people like Stephanie
[? Lin ?] and
Natalie, who's around,
who have built this thing
into what it is today.
So thank you to them
for having us here.
So what am I doing?
We are trying to build a
more awesome government
for the people, by
the people, today,
now, with groups like the
Presidential Innovation
Fellows, 18F, the United States
Digital Service, agencies
across the federal government,
and the White House.
So this is the group
that I am a part of.
And a little bit about how
I got involved with this.
I was just minding my
own business at Google,
doing analytics
internally for Google.
And I got this call from
Mikey at the White House,
who was just kind of starting
up the US Digital Service.
We were at eight or
10 people at the time.
And he basically said,
so we need someone
who knows health care and data.
Sounds like you might
know a few things.
Go come serve your country.
Come to the White House, and
help out for three months
because Google has a
sabbatical program that lets
you leave for three months.
Turns out I came
for three months.
My first day there, I
remember sitting in a room
with three of the most
incredible women I've ever
met or worked with and
thought, I can't go back.
Google is an amazing
place, but I can't go back.
This is my new home.
So I took a
three-month sabbatical
and stayed on with
the federal government
working on what is deemed
Obama's stealth startup, which
is basically a tech startup
inside the White House.
And I like to think of
it as the president's
kind of like our CEO.
The venture capitalists are
all the taxpayers-- all of you.
People are already paying
us for these services.
There's no reason
why they should suck.
And we need to make them better.
So that's why all these
amazing people in this photo
here are there in the
federal government--
some of the brightest
people I've ever met.
And I'll tell you more
about them going forward.
And I love this photo because
the president is sometimes
called the coder in chief.
He really did-- someone made
a side comment of, oh, he
probably didn't
really write any code.
And Megan stepped in
and was like, no, he
wrote a couple lines of Python.
So that was pretty exciting.
How often does that happen?
And we love this.
So I'll tell you
more about what we're
doing at the federal level.
And I'll go through a
couple of the projects
and give shout outs to a
couple of my colleagues
because they're
pretty incredible.
Some of you may have heard about
the healthcare.gov debacle.
Back in 2013, it was all
over CNN, all over Fox News,
all over all the news sources.
It was down.
Nobody could get access.
I remember in tech
circles, there
were talks of, why didn't they
just hire some of the best
technologists-- people
who've built the internet,
people who built
the best services
throughout the country?
And why did they hire
these crazy contractors?
It's because the federal
government spends,
I think, $80 billion
in contracts,
and 94% of those projects
are behind schedule.
And 40% never even
see the light of day.
It's just the state
of how we do things.
So healthcare.gov
was a part of that.
And a couple of people
across industry,
including some Googlers,
people like Mina Hsiang,
Mikey Dickerson, Matthew
Weaver, were like, I'm just
going to go help.
I'm going to go volunteer.
I know how to keep
google.com up,
so maybe I can keep
this website up.
And at that time, if you
look up this talk, I kid you
not-- the way this team figured
out if healthcare.gov was up,
is they turned on the
news, or they literally
went to healthcare.gov.
So for those of you who
have built products,
there were no analytics,
no way of tracking,
and the different teams
are not held accountable.
So we just brought
in things that
are best practices, are
normal here and in tech,
and turned that around.
And that team turned that
around so it's stable.
And millions of people were
able to get health care.
Over 100 million people who
were previously denied care
because of preexisting
conditions, that
were like you randomly get
cancer or some kind of disease,
now have access to care.
So that team was
pretty incredible.
Something else, an area
that I worked on-- Veterans.
Some of you may have
heard in the news
that some Vets wait two years,
a year and a half to get care.
Part of that is just a policy,
human resources problem.
Part of that is tech.
People come and submit
claims, and they just
don't get processed.
One example is this thing.
This took about 10 years
for contractors to build.
So the reason this exists--
it's for spinal cord injury
patients.
They have special motor
records and different kinds
of things that
are just different
than any other patient.
So they had to have
a special system.
So they hire contractors
to build this thing.
It came with a
133-page user manual.
Think of the last
time you've ever
had to even open a user manual.
You don't open one and figure
out how to use Google Maps.
How to use Gmail.
You don't open one to figure
out how to send an e-mail
or make a filter.
But that was the
state of technology.
So within a few months,
our team built something
in Postgres and Rails.
And one database.
Before, this was 24
different instances.
So if you ever asked anyone,
how many spinal cord injury
patients are there, you'd
get a different answer
across the board.
So there was no real
source of truth.
So this is a very
small, small project
that just showed
the power of what
you can do when you add
the patient and the user
to what you're building.
Immigration.
Some of you may
have had experience
trying to get a family
member into the US
or know people who
got married, and they
have these stories of waiting
months or years to get
their spouse into the US.
So some of that is
because it takes a while
to interview, et cetera.
But some of that is because
you have this massive mound
of paperwork to fill out.
And it's really
confusing, especially
if English maybe isn't
your first language.
So before, there was
something like this.
You had to go through the
website, figure out what
form you might need.
Is it an immediate relative?
Is it a third cousin?
Is it a spouse, et cetera?
It was really confusing.
That became this.
This team was led by
Vivian Graubard, who's
a technologist, an awesome
policy guru, who led this team
to turn that around
and make something
a little more user-friendly.
It means that something
like this-- a form you
had to fill out on
paper and mail in--
became something
like this, online,
that is much, much more
user-friendly and much more
familiar to many people today.
I love this slide.
Vivian included this in her
Grace Hopper-- her talk.
And somebody had found
this on the Metro
and gave it to her in DC.
So apparently picking up pieces
of paper in the Metro station
can be helpful.
What this is, is a list
of forms this person
had to fill out to get a
family member into the US.
And the $25,000
number at the bottom
is basically the
poverty line in the US.
So it's the amount
of money you have
to prove that you have in
order to support a family
member coming so
they don't become
a dependent of
the United States.
So it means that this
person had this number
at the top of their
mind, whatever
that might mean as a whole.
But overall, it's a really
crazy, confusing process.
Most people don't
go around and say,
I worked with USCIS
or immigration.
It was the best experience ever.
And I just recommend
it to everyone.
And that would be awesome
if we got to that.
It's not impossible, right?
We could make some
of these experiences
just as amazing as ordering
a car on your phone
or getting food delivered
to your house in 15 minutes.
So that's why we're here.
Education.
Many of you in this room
probably went to college.
And you may remember how hard
it was to just figure out
what schools to apply to.
If you just search
for best colleges,
you get this whole list,
ranging from "Business Insider,"
"Forbes," "Times"-- many,
many third party sites that
have totally arbitrary
ranking systems on how
they rank a college.
And that's what
students rely on.
The government has the
data, just in the past,
it hasn't really released.
It hasn't totally made it open.
So this was a team led
by Lisa Gelobter, who
did little things like helped
launch Hulu and executive
at BET, who is now part of the
federal government building
digital services.
Sarah Allen, who, if you've
ever used the internet,
have probably touched her
software because she founded
Flash and After Effects.
They came to work on
projects like this
because they in
their heart believe
the fastest way to
the middle class
is with a college education, and
they wanted to empower students
with better
decision-making tools.
This won't solve all of
our education problems
by any means, but at
least it's a first step
to let you know how much
universities actually
cost, real data on
graduation rates,
and real data on the salary that
people make after attending,
versus anything that
you might see out there
from a third party.
But what's most
powerful about this
is that it completely
opened up all the data,
and there's an API
behind this website.
What that means
is that any of you
can go and visualize that data
in any way you want and help
really make a difference.
It means nonprofits,
counselors, news sources
can go and pull this data
and have real, reliable data
to display to people.
That's pretty powerful.
That leads me into open data.
Just this idea of making
our government more
transparent for the people.
Cori Zarek, who is
a brilliant lawyer,
works on this in the Office of
Science, Technology, and Policy
with Megan Smith.
66 countries around the
world have collaborated
to work together to make sure
that all their governments make
their data open to
all of its people.
What that means is there
are sites like data.gov.
It's 160,000 sets of data.
If you're a data
wonk like me, you
can go, pull any
of those sets down,
and do whatever cool
visualizations you want,
ranging from business,
agriculture, education, energy,
police data, et
cetera, and come up
with really interesting
things about what's
going on in this country.
Or we have this thing called
the Digital Analytics Dashboard,
where you can see how
citizens are interacting
with all of our websites today.
What's even cooler about this
is that because everything was
also developed in the open, you
can grab the code from GitHub
today.
The city of Philadelphia has
their own Digital Analytics
Dashboard, and the
country of Mexico
is coming up with
their own data.gov.
It's pretty cool, and
we can collaborate
around the world that day
just through open code.
It's like techies
uniting around the world.
It's pretty awesome.
So last thing I'll
talk about is the thing
that is the absolute closest
and dearest to my heart.
Two things.
Number one, the Precision
Medicine Initiative.
The president announced
this last year
at the State of
the Union Address.
And the team of very
talented people,
like DJ Patil, Mina Hsiang,
and Claudia Williams
have been working together
to make this a reality.
So what's precision medicine?
It means that today, if you're
an 80-pound, 55-year-old Asian
woman or a 200-pound
Caucasian male,
and you came into
Stanford or any hospital
with acute lymphoblastic
leukemia, both of you
may get vincristine.
And the doctor
might say something
like, quote, "cross fingers
it might work this time"
and not know why
it doesn't work.
And not know why it works
for only a small part
of the population.
And you look at the two
people, and immediately think,
well, they're obviously just
two different human beings
with totally
different backgrounds.
And we don't have the data
to-- or we have the data,
but we don't have it compiled in
a way where we can analyze them
to figure out how two totally
different people will react
to the exact same
kind of treatment.
So we're looking to
do that, combining
genomics and background
data of people
to give better health
care to all people.
And then some of you may
have heard about something
called the Cancer Moonshot.
This is something that Vice
President Joe Biden feels
extremely passionate about.
It's something that several of
us here in the White House also
feel very passionate about.
And I particularly love this
name for multiple reasons.
One, I was a Googler,
and we always
used this to refer
to all the projects
that were kind of out there.
And then also, it kind
of came full circle
because the original
moonshot was our literal shot
to the moon, where
we went to the moon.
And some of these
things seem impossible.
It seems like it
might have not been
possible to go to the moon.
It seemed like having
hot air balloons give
Wi-Fi was impossible.
Self-driving cars.
And the thought of curing
cancer is something
that's thrown around a lot.
And sometimes that also
doesn't seem possible,
but we just believe
that we can do it.
So those are two of
the health initiatives
that just really, really
excite me that the White
House has its fingers in today.
So what that means is whether
you are in design, or product,
or policy, or engineering,
if your passion is education,
STEM, immigration, or
you just like solving
really crazy, giant, big,
tech problems that are really,
really, really hard with folks
who have the best intentions
but never really knew much
about user-centric design,
or shipping products, or
doing these number of things
that you may be used to
just in your industries,
there's so much room for
you to come help build
a more awesome government for
all the people, by all of us,
today at the local level,
at the federal level.
You can go work at any
city or state government.
Come to the federal
level at USDS,
18F, Presidential
Innovation Fellows,
work for Code for America,
where they are literally
coding for America, and help us
be a more awesome government.
And you can find out more at
whitehouse.gov/usds or reach
out to me and, we can
chat more after this.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So please, there are
mics around the room
if you all have questions.
And we have about, I think,
eight minutes for questions.
I think what I'll do is, I'll
call-- I was told that it's
best to call on the mic colors.
The yellow mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
Wonderful presentation.
So USDS is wonderful.
18F is wonderful.
These organizations
are wonderful.
What about having
other small companies
from Silicon Valley
who maybe are not
part of your
organization helping
to collaborate on
these projects--
is there a way for
them to do that?
KATHY PHAM: Yes.
So we're doing two things.
We have a whole
contracting team looking
into just looking
for ways to make it
so that it's easier for smaller
companies to contribute.
There actually was
a bug bounty that
was announced by the
Department of Defense
recently to invite people
to come and hack the DoD.
There are countless things like
that there we're building up.
There are ways to contribute
to any of the open source
projects, whether it's the
College Scorecard, data.gov,
Digital Analytics Dashboard.
You can find it
on the 18F GitHub.
There are plenty of projects
that you can contribute
on your own time without
actually moving to DC
or becoming a federal employee.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much
for your very inspiring speech.
I have a somewhat political
question, I guess.
With elections
coming up, how do you
see whoever is going to be
elected as the new president
supporting this undertaking?
KATHY PHAM: So we get this
question every single time.
And totally valid
question, something
we talk about all the time.
We've built our group
out into three tiers.
We have USDS at the White
House, which is where I sit.
We have the 18F
group, which is part
of what is called GS-- General
Service Administration.
So it's a whole different
agency, different funding
model.
It doesn't matter if
the president changes.
That group is
forever still there.
And then something cool
else that we also did.
Let me go back a slide.
If you look in the corner
there on the bottom right,
we've built out
digital service teams
within different agencies.
So we have a team within the VA.
We're building out a team within
Health and Human Services.
So when they're in
the agencies, when
the administration
changes, nothing
is going-- they'll
still be around.
So the only question is, we
have the funding for USDS
at the White House, and
there'll be leadership change
at the top, but
for the most part,
it will just be the
leadership churn.
And we'll just see what
happens with the groups-- we've
built it out in such a way that
the groups should be intact.
There's someone behind you.
AUDIENCE: My question is
also a little bit political.
It's not about Trump.
I was wondering,
like someone like me
who came from the
Middle East-- it took me
two years to get a work permit.
I was denied a tax
number because I'm
from a country
that doesn't exist,
which is called Palestine.
I was wondering, how do you
encourage people like me to get
excited about these projects?
It sounds inspiring.
It sounds amazing.
But it's really hard for me to
think that it's my government
when I'm treated this way.
My question is, how do
you get people excited
who are from different
countries and are here?
KATHY PHAM: Well, first,
we like to think ourselves
as-- we might work on a project
that might seem sometimes
political, but we're just not
a political group ourselves.
We just like to solve
hard tech problems.
And in the case of folks
who maybe immigrated here,
or who maybe just had a really,
really rough time figuring out
how to navigate our government,
we need your opinions.
We need people who understand,
why did it take you two years?
And why was it so hard?
And what does it mean to
be an unrecognized country?
And have that as part
of the user experience,
whether you're just contributing
via your thoughts and opinions
or coming to help
and turn that around,
to help us figure out how to
actually build for all people.
It might just be that
no one in that room--
similar to when
Google made a phone,
and it didn't take into
account left-handed people.
No one in the room
knew that use case,
and so we can't
design for people
when we don't have all
the people in the room.
So that's something else that
actually Megan focuses on a lot
as well.
So for those who,
like in your case,
you can maybe come
and help and actually
change that around
and make it better
for everyone else like you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the White House
did a demo day in 2015.
So can you talk a
little bit about what
are the plans for
the demo day in 2016,
and what's the spirit
behind it, and overall,
what other initiatives you
have for entrepreneurs?
KATHY PHAM: Yeah.
The demo day was hosted by the
Office of Science, Technology,
and Policy.
So I don't know
what their plans are
this year for the
results of the demo day.
We are constantly hosting
mapathons, and hackathons,
and different events like
that for entrepreneurs
to get involved.
And we actually need
lots of entrepreneurs
in groups like 18F and
USDS to drive forward
some of the initiatives
that we want to launch.
AUDIENCE: In what
ways was working
for the White House different
from working at Google?
Do you-- like, was
there more red tape?
Do you miss the free food?
KATHY PHAM: Yeah.
So many ways.
But then also not.
So I feel like the amazing
people themselves within USDS
and 18F are the same.
All the people that
Google has-- the passion,
the drive to use the best tech
to improve people's lives,
wanted to change
the world, wanted
to work on big things--
all of that's the same.
Launching products within
an agency is very hard.
It's just the reality
of things, partly
because things have
been built the same way
for many, many years.
Partly because we also pay
contractors multimillion
dollars to launch things.
Sometimes turning things
around and changing
people's minds can be difficult.
But the people that I work with
are by far the
most amazing people
I've ever worked
with in my life.
I actually don't
miss the free food.
I'd thought I might.
But I don't miss the free food.
And I think the
ability to just work
on something that is-- it's
probably the highest, greatest
impact thing I've ever done.
And partly because people are
already paying us, and the fact
that we're not delivering,
is not OK for any of us.
Whereas, when you work
for a corporation,
we have to build something
that people will want to buy.
Whereas for us, everyone--
if you're paying taxes,
you're already paying us, so
we'd better deliver things
that actually work.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I work at a DoD data
center down in Seaside.
And one of the problems
that we encounter
daily-- the developers
encounter daily--
is the software being
behind the times.
So do you know of
any initiatives
to bring the government up to
speed in technology or anything
like that?
KATHY PHAM: Yes.
There are definitely
initiatives to get
different parts of-- so
the government is built out
in multiple agencies-- I
think 25 or so agencies.
And you can think of each
one of as essentially having
its own CEO.
It's like a different country.
So I know different
agencies do it differently.
Like 18F is on Google
Docs and Google Apps,
and they have
Google Spreadsheets.
And then other groups are
still on Outlook and Lync
and different things.
Chris Lynch is the new
digital service lead
at the Department of Defense.
You should definitely
sync up with him
and see if you can mesh your
amazing minds together and come
up with other software that
would be better for the DoD.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious--
since the [INAUDIBLE]
conference we've been talking
about, diversity and inclusion.
How is that at USDS?
How is the diversity?
How is the inclusion?
KATHY PHAM: Thank you
for asking that question
because I love this question.
When we were building
USDS, something
that we were very
cognizant of was
that we all came
from tech companies
where the numbers
are pretty bad.
So if anything, at
the federal level,
we can try and at
least be an example.
We're 50% woman total, which
doesn't-- and then you're like,
well, what about the
breakdown, right?
Because it could be anything.
The last count
that we had, we're
35% female engineers, which is
better than the current numbers
in tech.
So that's pretty
exciting for us.
We have folks who've
recruited and hired--
and we're hiring
managers, and have
done all this at Google,
and LinkedIn, and Facebook,
and Twitter.
And we know some
of our pitfalls.
We're definitely not perfect.
There were arguments
in the early days,
like any startup,
of you guys can't
do that, or else
you're going to end up
with 5% women or 5% minorities.
I wish I had the numbers of
all the demographic breakdowns
off the top of my head.
I don't right now.
We might [INAUDIBLE]
maybe-- well actually,
I won't say anything
about that, but-- If you
were at Grace Hopper, or if
you just look at the topics
that I presented, it was a
pretty diverse group of women
that were presenting as well.
So we're extremely
cognizant of it.
We're very, very cognizant
at every single level-- when
we source, when we hire,
and we try and make
a very conscious effort to
make it a very diverse group
because we're building
for the American people.
So we should at
least try and get
most of what America looks like.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for the
inspiring speech.
I have one question.
So the one issue that I
struggle with every year
is when I have to do my taxes.
And I was just
wondering if you--
I don't know if it falls
within the purview-- but do you
have any initiatives going
on in that direction?
KATHY PHAM: Yeah.
We did a little bit of
advising over in the IRS space,
but there is no project
that we talk about publicly.
But yes, many of us also came
in the government and were like,
we have a really hard
time doing our taxes,
so let's figure
out some of this.
But there are initiatives, like
when you apply for a FASFA--
if you apply for a FASFA for
the Department of Education,
there's no reason why your
IRS data shouldn't also
automatically link to
your education data,
because it's all
the same government.
So there are things like
that have been worked on.
And I am out of time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]